Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one six area code. Who's calling today from
nine one six nine one six I heard you briefly
there, so I know your phone is working. Can
you hear me? Nine one six last opportunity.
Are you there? No. Nine one six that's too
bad. Let's go next to our caller from the
four six nine area code. Who's calling today
from four six nine.
Hello David. My name is Annie Rhodes. Can
you hear me?
Yes.
Oh, uh, first of all, congratulations on your
show. And he had a great decade. My question
has to do with United States nuclear policy
with Iran. So our primary goal foreign policy
objective was to prevent Iran from getting
the bomb. He had Obama's idea of the Iran
nuclear deal and you have Bolton's idea of
kind of Bama Rauner and bade them. So my question
is, is a bad, bad of a problem for rod to
get the bomb? Because we've seen in other
States like Indiana DocuSign ones where they
get the bomb, they actually have become less
confrontational and Pakistan only one war
against each other after they both got nuclear
weapons. And that war was basically a border
skirmish that lasted about two months. So
is it possible that if Iran gets a bomb, they
might be more open to negotiations and Mike
curb their finding of heads below? Are there
terrorist groups? I just want to know your
opinion of others because I don't hear a lot
of people discussing this opportunity.
So a couple things on that. I mean, number
one, anytime that people start saying this
country should or shouldn't have nuclear weapons,
it gets to, okay, well who gets to decide
whether that is or isn't the case? And then
there's a conversation about the validity
of the United nations security council and
who are Americans who have tons of nuclear
weapons to tell another country they can't
have them. That's a debate. And let's put
that aside so we can actually deal with the
question that you're asking. If I were to
say what you're, what you're suggesting is
completely plausible, but what might be different
in Iran? I'm open to having my mind changed,
but it seems that the powers that be in Iran
are different than those in India and in Pakistan.
Would you say that that is a, a material difference
in exploring this or, or maybe not?
I'm not exactly sure about that. I don't think
that because at least Pakistan and Iran are
both Islamic republics. They both have a very
hard religious streak. But at the same time
I, as much as Pakistan hates India, the leaders
in Pakistan who have the thumb on nuclear
button don't hate Indians that much, that
they hate them more than they love living
themselves because nuclear weapons are such
a short way of mutual destruction that no
one is going to use it. And anytime you put
powers are at conflict, they will always be
escalate to negotiations.
Oh yeah, this is not so, so I actually, it's
not discussed enough and it should be, and
it is something that I've read about and it's
at least um, at face value, it is a, a, a
practical consideration. I'd have to do more
thinking about how it would apply to Iran
specifically. But it is not a crazy thing
to suggest.
Yeah. But my question for this came because
I realized that you have to spend a lot of
resources and burning a lot of bridges trying
to ensure that Iran doesn't have a nuclear
bomb. Whereas I think that might be more productive
if instead of focusing so hard, like focusing
on reaching out to Iran or trying to do like
a hearts and minds campaign to ease tensions
between the countries rather than trying to
keep Iran down in a situation where that's
harmful for the U S as well.
It's a very fair point and I appreciate you
making it. I'm going to think more about it
and maybe it'll be worthy of a, a, of a followup
discussion. I really appreciate the phone
call. Uh, sorry to everybody I didn't get
to this year, but we will take calls again
in 2020 before you know it, it'll be here.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more
right after this.